[Music]
there's a lot of places that don't let
me perform simply because I'm black and
that doesn't really get to me because
I'm trying to show the world that you
know music is universal it can unite us
all my name is Ryan Lory and I'm also
known as campanero and compañero simply
means the black friend I see original
music Americana panda CEO Daniel Norteno
mariachi little I've been around
Hispanic so I mean it actually comes
natural in me it flows out I grew up in
the streets of Compton I lived in a
neighborhood that was predominantly
black and Mexican it's a wonderful thing
to say you know I came from Compton
because they say a lot of people don't
make it out I've traveled to a lot of
places and I'm all over TV and I can say
hey I'm from Compton
a lot people tell me like hey you were
supposed to be Mexican god just left in
the oven too long I know for a fact that
I am african-american but yeah I do feel
like I live that life I have lived and
run shadow life I've had horses I've had
roosters goats pigs everything I know
how to saddle up a horse you're not I
making dance and everything a lot of
people misunderstand and say hey you're
trying to be Mexican too much I'm like
wall there are American Cowboys there
are people who use boots and just that's
what I was taught what I've been around
but yes like I said on my saga but like
I said in my song I have the heart and
soul of a Mexican and that I think that
that pretty much is what counts
[Music]
to play the instrument that is utilizing
our gentle earth it's like you are
becoming one with the instrument in a
very true way you just sit and go yes
we're looking at the grates two leg pipe
organ of the Luray Caverns in Luray
Virginia when I press a key it sends an
electrical pulse up to a rubber tipped
mallet which strikes the stalactite
causing it to vibrate and producing a
incredibly beautiful musical tone the
area that the strikers cover is roughly
three and a half acres which then makes
it literally the world's largest musical
instrument it is a very gentle sound
very peaceful there's only one like it
in the world and it's something
incredibly different and wonderfully
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blues is our feeling and it is in
experience blues is about something that
happens in my life my name is Beverly
Watkins I was born here in Atlanta
Georgia in 1939 Beverly Watkins was a
pioneer for women it blues when I was
playing back in the sixties there wasn't
no female guitar players not in Georgia
they said I play like a man but they're
using the wrong terminology the main
thing is because I play so good after
high school Beverley began touring with
the band piano red and the meter tones
shortly thereafter she was opening for
some of the biggest acts in music we
opened up for James Brown BB King Otis
Redding
I played over two or three thousand
shoulders back in those days the artists
took time and hope each other
her hard classic blues style has evolved
over the last sixty years touring with
different bands and eventually going
solo
I never stopped when they said I should
I didn't pay him no mind I kept going
yes it has gotten hard out there you
know I clean houses I worked at car
washes I clean offices but I never
stopped playing my music
and she has no plans on stopping anytime
soon
well into her 70s she still puts on a
show for the crowd
it is keeping me Libyan keeping me gone
I'm gonna look good and have a good time
and get up there and do my thing
[Music]
I went to the darkest places I could
ever go drugs violence everything when I
went on a Vision Quest the Vision Quest
it's like your true calling for me its
[Music]
[Music]
first name Jeremiah stage name is Jesus
I am from decree in Anishinabe tribes
coming up in school native kids were
always looked at like dirty alcoholics
all the stereotypes it really felt like
we didn't have a voice so hip-hop became
my voice in the beginning I thought that
I had to be hard
hip-hop is about reality and as I grew I
started to really speak about stuff that
was really going on with me as opposed
to always kept trying to that tough guy
the song we're party was such an
important moment in my life I was really
speaking to the warrior in me the males
to the warrior within us all baby no
faking here for the fans I'm shutting
out Bobby Jones my auntie my mushroom
George and John and all of my strength
for my people here before me man
a lot of native people we don't see too
many other native people succeeding we
like to stay in the dark and maybe
that's because we were pushed into the
dark for how many centuries maybe we're
comfortable there now I'm not cool with
that but we're trying to bring us into
the light you know I'm ready to go and I
want to bring my people with me back
then we get a lot of guys playing that
white boy music and we really don't
listen to that you know and it's going
too fast to finally get to a place where
there is now a sea of all the rainbows
of people but a lot of black kids there
we're at the point of progress I hear
from a lot of people in color safe and
you guys made it okay for me to feel
like it was alright to be black in the
rock I hear that a lot
Brooklyn's afro punk music festival was
born in 2005 for alternative black
culture but before there was a space for
celebration a strong handful of bands
were paving the way like the band
fishbone
my name is Angelo more frontman of
fishbone I'm John Knoll official basis
for fishbone fishbone was formed in the
late 70s
and it was a Los Angeles 1978 when too
many bands who look like this because at
all black band playing punk rock and sky
he's probably counting on one hand the
crazy part about it was while we were
starting to play a lot of rock and roll
we really weren't embraced too much
about a black public we were embraced a
lot about white bumpers so we get a lot
of white kids coming to the show black
people ain't supposed to play rock
that's not the stereotype black people
are supposed to play RB & funk and soul
if you got dreadlocks use boogie playing
reggae put on a suit and tie you play
you can play jazz right afropunk is the
celebration of rock and roll black music
for everyone it's incredible and it
draws in youth of color to say this is
for you and in a larger way than we do
you can be the beautiful black you and
rock
[Music]
you
[Music]